conçue dès le début des années 60 le
jaguar a volé pour la première fois en
septembre 1968
fruit d'une collaboration franco
britannique
le jaguar est un de ces avions
exceptionnelle qui rassemble toute leur
carrière durant des fanatiques du monde
entier
laventure du jaguar a commencé en 1973
pour prendre fin en cette année 2005
elle aura duré 37 années pendant
lesquelles il aura participé à un nombre
impressionnant de conflit
en mai 1966 et former la cpccaf société
commune pour la production du jaguar
elle rassemble breguet aviation et
british aircraft corporation
en juin de la même année deux motoristes
créé la rolls royce turbomeca limiteur
ont développé l'adour réacteurs à double
flux
le jaguar présente une masse à vide de
75 pour une masse au décollage de 14
tonnes 5
les deux réacteurs à dour mk 102 qui
l'équipe d'une poussée de trois mille
deux cent cinquante kilos chacun lui
permet d'atteindre la vitesse de mach 1
35 à 1 plafond de 12500 m
le jaguar largement exporté présente une
grande variété de versions dont une
biplace destinés à l'école
même si le jaguar français n'a pas
bénéficié des mêmes raffinement que ses
homologues britanniques ils ne cessèrent
jamais d'évoluer tout au long de leur
carrière
recevant tout particulièrement une
cartographie numérique un gps et des
leurres plaqué sous les ailes en 2004
ces avions ont toutefois été qualifiée
d' ancien carreleur pilotage demande est
fort et attention le jaguar n'ai donc
rien sans ses pilotes et c'est sans
doute pour cette raison que ceux-ci
l'adorent
on
l'escadron 1,7 provence possède la
particularité d'avoir été le premier à
accueillir le jaguar en 1973 et de le
voir faire ses adieux en 2005
l'escadron de chasse 1 7 provence unités
de la force aérienne de combat se
singularise par deux missions
principales
l'aso conventionnelle d'objectifs
terrestres et maritimes et la
reconnaissance
fort de plus de 200 personnes le 1 7
assure encore quotidiennement des
missions de reconnaissance
photographique de la plus haute
importance stratégique
les pilotes s'entraînent ou non sur des
habituels de combat opérationnel et
travaille activement l'assaut
conventionnelles en équipe où on isolé
malgré son ancienneté
le jaguar surprend encore par sa
capacité à accomplir des missions
délicates et par sa robustesse
aucun pilote ne par envol sans effectuer
un tour complet de l'avion en compagnie
des pistards le pilote effectué les
vérifications de l'ensemble des
commandes de vol et de sécurité maxime
thomas ce pilote au 1,7 nous invita le
sud est juste aujourd'hui
alors à bord dégager quelques
extincteurs en place mano 15 cents 200
30min près statique - de roulement
amortisseurs bouclier phare rhodoïd s'en
dégage est rappelé et n'a fermé la
perche pâte 8 incidence libre s'en
dégage et rap oxygène fermé d'ohrid prix
statique des pertes iter jeu l'état qui
branché en évident bidons vides le
sécurité à jacques semble interrupteurs
et vers l'avant trope additionnel
il est verrouillé chargé il est
débranché sur 0,5 verrouillé monde de
roulement bloc de freins amortisseurs
très fiers but renfermé qui ont été
enlevés porte impulseur fermé bidons
pleins plat québec libre libre volée pas
de jeu pas l'impact
pas de jeu par l'impact fourchette en
place madoff
on a quinze 115-108 permet pas de
témoins freiner ou vers l'acquis
collector volet tiers ph pas de jeu pas
l'impact kodmani en place ph pas de jeu
pas l'impact
collector volé depuis hier les plats
qu'ils sont fermés
sécurité crasse enlever la passe qui est
en place l'acquis
mano rester - switch voulait pas que
j'ai pas d'impact est fait en place
parce que j'ai pas l'impact plaquettes
bac libre libre ses qualités andré porte
un pull serait refermée vie donc là
bande de roulement club de cahors foot
africain
en porte verrouillée porte un t-shirt
fermé s'il est verrouillé chargé et
débrancher
le jaguar peut effectuer des missions de
longue durée c'est un capacités de
ravitaillement en vol
associée à celle de nombreux encore de
munitions lui ont permis de basculer
très vite dans l'emploi opérationnel
mon nom
son autonomie en vol étant de l'ordre de
1400 km il est amené régulièrement au
cours de sa mission à ravitailler
réalisé par le pilote lui même à une
époque où l'emport de matériel de prise
de vue était encore autorisée
nous vous proposons d'assister en direct
à une manoeuvre de ravitaillement auprès
d'un boeing kc 135 du grv bretagne
selon le modèle la perche de
ravitaillement peut se trouver sur le
flanc droit de l'appareil et se
déployait au moment du ravitaillement
le pilote opère toujours selon le même
mode il arrive à l'arrière droit du
tanker jusqu'au visuel et attend
l'autorisation du boom chargé d'assurer
la manoeuvre pour glisser vers la gauche
afin de se placer dans laxe du poste de
ravitaillement qui lui a été désigné
ces images montrent à quel point la
marge de manoeuvre est étroite pour le
pilote
celui ci dispose en gros d'un volume
équivalent à un cube de 1 mètre de côté
pour manoeuvrer sa perche
une fois que l'accrochage a eu lieu dans
l'entonnoir du kc 135
le pilote du jaguar doit en quelque
sorte pousser celui ci
le tuyau qui relie alors les deux
appareils ne doit pas se retrouver
tendue au risque d'arracher l'extrémité
de la perche ce qui aurait pour
conséquence d'interrompre leur
ravitaillement et d'endommager gravement
le matériel
lorsque l'opération est terminée sur
ordre du tanker le pilote du jaguar
décroche sa perche et s'éloigne du
boeing en glissant vers sa gauche
jusqu'au contact visuel avec l'équipage
qui lui donnera l'autorisation de faire
un break à gauche pour reprendre sa
mission
oh
vous
lorsque l'appareil dispose d'une perche
centrale la manoeuvre est identique à la
différence près que l'installation est
fixe sur l'avion
dans le cadre d'une mission de
reconnaissance photographique le pilote
utilise la caméra au maire à 42 75 mm
situé dans le nez de l'appareil
ou alors le rp 36 dotée de trois caméras
au maire à 42 600 mm
aussitôt la patrouille poser les
techniciens du service photo des pauses
la boîte à films du nez de l'avion pour
remettre celle ci au laboratoire
on
à son tour le laboratoire photographique
récupère le précieux film pour le
soumettre à un process de développement
qui le rendra exploitables par les
officiers du renseignement
une fois révélée et fixer les images
sont déposés à l'escadron dans un local
prévu à cet effet et à la disposition
des équipages
oh
vous
exception faite des missiles purement rr
comme le super 530d et le mica le jaguar
a emporté tous les types d'armements
avec en point d'orgue le missile
nucléaire aen 59
sur le parking l'activité est intense
les armuriers installe les bombes sous
l'avion
au cours de ces exercices toutes les
catégories seront employées de la bombe
de 250 kilos à la bombe d'une tonne
reposez la range verdict
sound
avant de partir en vol les pilotes
effectuent le tour avion afin de
s'assurer que les munitions sont bien en
place sur leur support tous les pilotes
de l'escadron participe régulièrement à
des campagnes de tir sur la base de
cazaux
ces campagnes leur sont indispensables
pour acquérir ou entretenir les
connaissances et la pratique nécessaire
et pour l'utilisation optimale du
matériel par ailleurs l'escadron sert de
support au centre d'expériences
aériennes militaires le ceam à marsan
pour les expérimentations en vol le ceam
utilisent régulièrement le jaguar pour
tester les nouveaux armements guidée
laser
le capitaine phillips zuccarelli nous
raconte une campagne de tirs la campagne
de tirs c'est une valeur ajoutée dans le
tir d'armement où on va tirer dans un
premier temps des munitions d'exercice
aussi bien des obus que des bombes
et puis ensuite on va tirer des armes
bonne de guerre c'est-à-dire des bombes
de 250 kilos des bombes de 125 kg et
puis des bombes à haute valeur ajoutée
je dirais c'est les bombes guidées laser
plusieurs fois par jour les pilotes
grammes dans leurs avions pour des
missions de tir
la dizaine de jaguar mis en oeuvre pour
l'occasion se livre à un ballet
incessant sur le parking
on
dans l'arrêté
les objectifs sont divers en fait il ya
aidant il ya beaucoup de choses
peut faire avec ces armements et
notamment de l'appui feu qui est en fait
une partie
de notre mission c'est à dire après
description d'un target via un
un personnel au sol eh bien on va
rallier notre nacelle sur l'objectif qui
nous désignent et puis illuminé et tirer
une bombe dessus ça peut être aussi bien
un char un bâtiment ça peut être une
position ennemie
c'est très varié
grosse contrainte pour nous c'est que en
fait il faut acquérir très tôt le visuel
delà de l'objectif c'est à dire
de l'ordre de 20 km avant l'objectif
pour pouvoir ou plutôt rallier ce pote
de désignation sur l'objectif est
ensuite pouvoir conduire une
un guidage et rejoindre des éléments
tirs dans la fenêtre désiré puisque la
charge de travail à ce moment-là du
pilote est énorme
dans un premier temps on arrive sur un
cap d' approche à une altitude donné on
va
cherchez visuellement en cabine
la position du l'objectif on va rallier
le pote de désignation laser à ce qu'on
voit grâce à une croix désignation dans
l'avion en tête haute
une fois qu'on a rallié la position eh
bien on sait que le faisceau laser futur
qui va illuminer la cible sera au centre
d'un au centre d'une croix à l'intérieur
de cette de cette télé et lorsqu on
lancera la bombe est bien en même temps
on en sera un laser en fait une
désignation laser qui permettra la bombe
de se quitter suivants 7
ce faisceau laser les obus et bien ce
sont des armes simple conte tiré
exactement qu'on va tirer exactement
comment tirer pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale c'est à dire qu'on a un viseur
et puis en mettant en venant rejoindre
des paramètres
pré calculées et bien on va tirer dans
ces conditions là pour remettre les obus
au but
les bombes
conventionnel ce sera exactement la même
chose donc au sol on prévoit le dire
avec des paramètres et puis lorsque
et lorsqu'on arrive sur le chantier on
vient rejoindre les paramètres qu'on
avait défini et en tire dans ces
paramètres
en revanche les armements guidée laser
et bien c'est différent puisque la
précision on demande d'avoir une
précision métrique donc forcément
on va prévoir donc 1 4 tirs au sol qui
est une rejointe de paramètres on
appelle ça une fenêtre de tir
c'est à dire c'est quelque chose de plus
vaste donc qui va permettre une
concentration concentré se concentrait
moins sur la partie pilotage pour
pouvoir se concentrer sur la partie
guidage donc là et bien avec 1 1 on a un
espèce de potes désignation laser en
aéroportée qu'on va emmener avec nous
sous l'avion qui va te permettre de
rechercher l'objectif dans un premier
temps désigné
l'objectif est ensuite avec une
élimination laser eh bien on va guider
la munition vers l'objectif que l'on
qu'elle en illumine le jaguar est équipé
de deux canons des uefa 553 de 30
minutes
ces armes seront aussi utilisés pour
plusieurs passes de tirs que réalisent
les pilotes sur les cibles du champ de
tir
il
le jaguar est propulsé par deux
réacteurs addou a post combustion
ces moteurs économes en carburant confer
l'avion une manoeuvrabilité apprécié par
les pilotes en navigation basse altitude
le jaguar possède ainsi une grande
autonomie
malgré un manque de pousser et un faible
taux de montée le jaguar se défend
d'être est bien en combat aérien
rapproché en sachant utiliser les volets
et avec un pilotage aux fesses ils
prenaient souvent davantage face aux
mirage iii ou f1 par un tir au calme
malgré tout le soin apporté à
l'entretien de l'appareil
il se peut que l'un des moteurs
présentent des pannes
la réparation si elle est sommaire est
effectuée directement sur le parking par
les mécaniciens
dans le cas d'une panne plus sérieuses
le moteur doit être déposé en atelier
cette opération spectaculaire et qui
nécessitent un outillage spécifique
demande une vingtaine d'heures de main
d'oeuvre
elle est aisément réalisé par deux
personnes
deux bassins seront bientôt quelqu'un
pour une tournée
il tire un peu ce cave nazi mouline bon
ce rapport
le moteur déposée de l'avion et expédié
à le sts dans cet atelier spécialisé le
réacteur sera entièrement révisée et
remis en état
cet établissement situé sur la base mais
elle assure également l'ensemble des
opérations de visite et d'entretien
périodique du moteur
le réacteur refait est installé sur
l'avion qui va pouvoir partir faire son
point sur
situé à l'extrémité de la base une aire
spécialement aménagée accueille les
appareils à tester
sécurisé par une cabine antibruit les
mécaniciens effectué un essai de pousser
maxi et de post combustion avant de
ramener l'avion en atelier pour reposer
les taux de riz capotage moteur
alors que l'obscurité se fait dans le
hangar l'activité de l'escadron ne
s'arrête pas pour autant
l'entraînement des pilotes se prolonge
au cours d'un vol de nuit
m
ce moment privilégié permet aux
passionnés que nous sommes d'oublier
quelques instants la technique pour se
consacrer à l'admiration des préparatifs
au décollage qui aura lieu dans une
lumière de rêve
à
relié à la base par les opérateurs du
contrôle aérien les avions vont
effectuer leur vol tard dans la nuit
pour nous offrir un spectacle de toute
beauté
servi par des hommes et des femmes
passionnés
le jaguar a accompli une tâche sans
précédent c'était un avion conçu pour
faire la guerre tant pour les pilotes
que pour les mécaniciens être sur jaguar
était synonyme de déplacement et d'
aventure que l'on vivait une fois
avant que le jack disparaissent dans la
nuit de nos mémoires regardons une
dernière fois cet oiseau majestueux qui
fut pour beaucoup le plus beau des
avions